11 miles an hour
[Music]
northern california
this is
like
um
foreign
um
um
here's how much i talk about my telethon
foreign
you
um
lowercase
you don't know me
oh
uh
but it doesn't help
what
um
okay
oh
more difficult
um
you
come on
um
i mean that's true
alrighty
okay
so
good morning everyone
we are so pleased with the actions taken
by the house of representatives
last night last night we made it
just a giant step for democracy some of
you heard us talk about it
on the steps of the capitol led by john
sarbanes
and zoe lofgren uh who are the masters
of putting hr1 together
and also other members speaking
including
terry sewell who is the author of hr4
the voting rights act we wave
flags in honor of our democracy that's
this legislation
is there to protect the right to vote
to remove obstacles of participation
hr one for the people
for the people the first 300 pages were
written by john lewis
to remove voter suppression
uh tactics from our political system
some of the rest of it was written to
protect
the integrity of our electoral system
the effect the
the physical infrastructure of our
elections
important in the legislation is to stop
foreign interference in our election
to reduce the role of big dark special
interest
money again to have
redistricting done by commission and not
by
partisan redistricting to have
voters choose their elected officials
rather than elected officials choose
their voters
to honor small donors by having matching
funds in that regard
and again removing the role of big
dark special interest money
in our electoral process and our
governmental
process what's exciting
about it is that it restores confidence
that people have that their vote and
their voice
is as important as anyone's that yes we
can address the climate crisis
if big dark special interest money is
not
suffocating the our airwaves with
misinformation
about how we protect the planet that we
yes can have
a background checks passed in the whole
congress of the united states to protect
our children
if big dark special interests gun
lobbying money is not suffocating the
airways
and yes we can have lower cost of
prescription drugs the list goes
on and on we can build back
better for the people in every zip code
as we said in our caucus yesterday build
back better for the people
advancing justice
opportunity and prosperity in every zip
code
also last night we pulled
forward the bill that we were going to
bring to the floor this morning
for a vote we had a short
schedule today because the republicans
are going to
going to their issues conference we had
ours virtually
here but they're going to there so this
was only going to be
other votes in the morning on that one
bill uh the debate and votes on that
bill
and we decided to do that last night
and that was the george floyd justice in
policing act
it's pretty exciting to have a big
strong democratic vote
for that we had wished it would be
bipartisan
it is something that we all take great
pride in
millions of the people worldwide
marched came out peacefully demonstrated
just said enough enough when they saw
george floyd lynched
before their very eyes for eight minutes
and 46 seconds
congress has not act we passed the bill
last year
we passed it again this year we feel
very
optimistic that there must be some
bipartisanship here
in the senate karen bass was the master
of this and she
she is in negotiation in the on the
senate side on this legislation
but nonetheless we took great pride and
the fact that we were able to pass it
last night on the floor of the house
members
quoting him i can't breathe i can't
breathe
or calling for his mother calling for
his mother
now this bill will not bring him back or
briana taylor
say say her name brianna taylor bring
them back
but hopefully it will prevent i say that
as one raised in a political family
where we were taught as we grew up to
honor the the men was that long time ago
the men in blue be true to the men
in blue now we would say the men and
women in blue we respect
what our first responders do for us
to protect us they leave home sometimes
not knowing
if they're coming home because of any
danger they may be in protecting the
rest of us
on many occasions we're present at the
annual event to
um i'm sayers who's like those whose
lives are lost
so this is not without respect for those
in our
in blue who protect us but it is
that respect should not be a path to
apathy
in regard to those who are not honoring
their profession and who are unduly
unduly doing violence to so many of our
young people
especially in the black community
and here we are the senate has received
our rescue package
earlier this week on monday and now they
are
uh acting upon it
we're very excited about the prospect
at the at the end of this week or the
beginning of next i don't know their
schedule it depends on how many uh bills
some of the an amendment some of the
republicans want
uh to be read but that's i don't know
so much about the uh shall we say the
wisdom of that
however or the value of the time of some
of the
people who are proposing that but
nonetheless
we will in a matter of several days
be sending two back to the house and
then we'll send
to the president the american rescue
plan
the biden american rescue plan
which we're very very proud of which as
we say puts
vaccines in the arms of the american
people
money in the pockets of the american
people
children in school safely and workers
back into their jobs among other things
we're very proud of the legislation we
wish the senate well in its
deliberations this is the
this is congress working its will we
send our product
they'll act upon it
apparently there will be some changes so
it will come back to the house
uh we'll review it and send it to the
president if you have any questions
yes sir uh speaker pelosi i was just
wondering
what role the security threat played in
moving the votes from uh this morning to
last night
does that send the wrong message no i
don't think so uh we
as i said earlier this was going to be a
very uh
we were going to be out by noon because
we promised that to the republicans we
would not prolong anything
because they are going to their uh their
issues conference uh we had ours
virtually this week as you may be aware
i hope you are and uh and their theirs
was starting
uh around now in another
hour we would be uh at the latest we
would be adjourning so they can go on
theirs
so it was really just as a convenience
and frankly
there are a lot of us you know they're
senators in and they should be in that
we're for at least four times more
people
and therefore all that that implies in
terms of
numbers of people in the capital if in
fact
uh there's any troublemakers around
and uh it made sense i i don't
think anybody should take any
encouragement that because
some troublemakers might show up that we
changed our whole schedule no we just
moved it a few hours
and it largely will accommodate the
republicans going
uh to their own session
there are reports that the capitol
police have asked the national guard to
stay for two additional months
how long they've been here do you think
that needs exists do you agree
you want them to continue to stay here
well
that's a question for them the decisions
about security
are made by the security uh leadership
here and we'll see what that ask is
right now we have some drafts
that have been put together a draft that
has been put together
by general honore he's briefing all the
leadership of committees in a bipartisan
way leadership of the congress
and hopefully next week we'll have a
presentation we'll be able to have
presentations to the fuller
membership uh the
issue about the national guard is one uh
that will be made
by the the capitol police and the police
board and the rest
but i'm not in a position to respond to
that
but we should have them here as long as
they are needed and the
silliness of this being inauguration day
and that in may
the president will be uh insult
inaugurated is
falls into the realm of uh let's not
waste our time on it
but in terms of that what we need we
have to have what we need when we need
it
and in the numbers of that we need it
but that's
a security decision yes sir
yes ma'am thank you ma'am speaker about
the rescue plan
uh critics including senator mitch
mcdonald with said the expansion of
obamacare insurance subsidies
will disproportionately benefit welfare
people
and they argue that the refugee plan
could give subsidies to households
making
300 000 or more and also discarded
people
uh going to going to work from going to
work are you talking about the
affordable care act
yes expansion in the rescue now this is
this is
this is a two-year extension of
an improvement on the affordable care
act so that
the subsidies would be available to the
next tier of income
people it's not about wealth if they
want to talk about wealth they should
look at their
own tax scam that they passed in the
dark of night
and the speed of light that gave 83 of
the benefits the top
1 forcing nearly 2 trillion
of debt on our children uh for to pay
in the future in order to give tax
breaks to the high end
they ought not to be uh complaining
about some people making
a little more money getting a subsidy
yes sir back there um you mentioned uh
sentencing possibly late because of an
amendment reading
on the uh on the rescue plan late i i
don't know if i said late i mean
you mean late at night yeah oh i don't
know how late to say i don't have
anything about their schedule
um staying longer yeah stay longer
um at the beginning of the year there
was also a kerfuffle over the organizing
resolution
there are still nominations that are
worth making their way through the
process um i'm wondering do you think
that republicans are
intentionally trying to delay as much
action on democratic priorities as
possible
because they think that you guys will
lose the house next year
i don't i don't know you'd have to ask
the republicans about that
i would be uh it would be curious to
think
that the republicans in the senate uh
are enthusiastic about reading the bills
and all the amendments
and in fact the characterization of what
happened on january 6
what which was posed by that very same
senator
uh who wants to read uh all of that so i
i can't
i can't speak to their motivation you
have to ask them
madam speaker yes
thank you madam speaker um there are
some bipartisan
talks about another war powers
resolution
and i was wondering if there's any
discussion within the caucus and would
they have your support
well we did uh in the committees of
jurisdiction
of course uh there's always talk about
the aumf
that's an ongoing conversation that we
have had
uh and of course that relates to the war
powers
resolution but as a
caucus we spent the last few days
on our economic agenda for how we go
forward
also how we uh respect people in our
communities that what uh
in terms of of uh communities of color
uh immigrant communities and the rest so
it was more of a domestic
uh uh we did have anthony blanken the
secretary of state
speak about some national security
issues
he was fabulous it was a beautiful
values-based visionary presentation
but in terms of the committees of
jurisdiction that would be the armed
services committee others on the
appropriations committee that apply to
that
yeah i'm sure we'll be having of those
conversations
yeah yes ma'am madam speaker with
respect to the honorary review
some details have leaked out as far as
adding more than a thousand capital
police officers having retractable
fencing and also having a quick reaction
of course do you support
those findings well the uh the fact that
uh there are some it's a draft
it's a draft and so we're seeing the
draft and we'll review the draft and
then
uh hear what the uh our security
folks have to say about the draft as
well
i'm not here to talk about any
particulars of it
but i have enormous respect for general
honore i think it is
a blessing to us that he was willing to
take the responsibility
to engage so many others who are with
law enforcement
and national security
expertise uh to
look at the situation here about how
this
what happened from a security standpoint
and how we could have prevented it and
how we prevent it
in the future perhaps next week we will
be presenting
uh to the fuller body and at at some
point
have decisions made about what is
feasible it'll have to have a
supplemental it's going to take more
money to protect the capital in a way
that enables people to come here
children to come and see our democracy
in action
all of you to cover uh what happens here
safely members to be comfortable that
they
are safe when they are here and not be
uh concerned about
uh what happened last time but that that
just doesn't have a place
in a democracy and that's why today
again it has not impeded us because we
only had a small
agenda for this morning big in terms of
george floyd
bill but the rule had been passed
earlier in the week so it was just the
hour of debate and then the vote
on the bill which we could easily
accommodate last night
but between covet where we need
to have vaccinations more broadly in the
capital so that many more people
can come here and do their jobs
and uh the threat of them
of all the president's men out there uh
we have to we have to ensure
with our security uh that we are
safe enough to do our job but not
impeding i mean i live in san francisco
so people said well if you want to be
totally protected
by from earthquakes you just live in a
like a an iron igloo
and then you're completely safe well who
wants to do that
so how do we make the judgments of what
is needed
uh to protect ourselves uh from the uh
what has been described by the director
of the
fbi as domestic terrorists
and how we protect ourselves against
that makes covid look almost
doable because it is just a matter of of
money and vaccine etc etc
so in any event we're ready for the task
we have expert guidance and
intellectual resources available to us
and we will make decisions and
prioritize it's about prioritizing
how we go forward but it is uh
it's going to be a great day as the
senate proceeds with the legislation
we're thrilled with what we were able to
accomplish
last night and uh it'll be a concept for
celebration when we pass
the the um rescue package
and at the same time we are already
moving forward with the recovery
with the recovery package uh so it's an
exciting time i
i hope you felt safe coming in today uh
we're way ahead of where we were last
time because we have fences and we have
national guard and the rest
but nonetheless we don't want to have
all of that
we want to have our capital be respected
uh by everyone in our country so that
as lincoln did during the civil war he
he said we're going to build the dome
so that people know that we are
proceeding
and that's really what our spirit is
thank you all very much
oh